Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
Bienvenidos a este último Carrusel de
las artes que les presentamos desde el
balneario de cannes el Festival
Internacional de Cine llegó a su término
y se lo contamos ya mismo
[Música]
el festival de cannes cerró por todo lo
alto con la tradicional gala de entrega
de los premios en este programa los
principales galardones de esta edición y
sobre todo la palma de oro a la mejor
película fuimos al encuentro del chileno
Felipe Gálvez quien sorprendió con los
colonos película que aborda un capítulo
oscuro de la historia de chile
presentada en la selección oficial una
cierta mirada y también en Carrusel de
las artes el director argentino Rodrigo
Moreno autor de los delincuentes una
cinta inteligente con derroche de
referencias al séptimo arte
[Música]
fueron 12 días de estrellas sorpresas y
muchos cine de autor el Festival
Internacional de Cine de cannes 2023
bajo el telón con la última subida de la
alfombra roja seguida de la gala de
entrega de los premios
[Música]
por segunda vez en la historia una
directora francesa alzó La palma de oro
a la mejor película en el festival de
cannes Y esa mujer fue Justin tillyette
quien presentó en este certamen la cinta
anatomía de una caída la historia del
juicio contra una mujer acusada de haber
asesinado a su marido
esta cinta límpida precisa y austera que
cosechó excelentes críticas en cannes y
que termina siendo una disección
implacable de la vida en pareja la
directora Frances aprovechó su discurso
para criticar la reforma de las
pensiones en Francia al tiempo que
dedicó su premio a los nuevos cineastas
la mercantilización de la cultura que
este gobierno defiende está acabando con
la excepción cultural francesa ese
Premio lo dedico a los jóvenes
directores y directoras e incluso a
aquellos que hoy no pueden hacer sus
películas debemos darles un espacio el
mismo espacio que yo vine a ocupar hace
15 años
la bellísima actriz Jane Fonda fue la
encargada de entregar la estatuilla
dorada recordando que en esta edición
hubo un récord con siete mujeres
cineastas en la competencia de cannes
el galardón al mejor director fue para
el Franco vietnamita por su drama la
pasión de
pone de relieve el amor de un fino
gourmet y su fiel cocinera en el siglo
XIX por su parte el director quentin
tarantino y el veterano Roger corman
entregaron el gran premio al británico
Jonathan glacer por su muy impresionante
the shown off interest la historia de
una familia nazi que vive cómodamente al
lado de un campo de Exterminio en su
clausura el festival de cannes resaltó
su lado más internacional hubo discursos
en francés inglés japonés coreano Turco
y finlandés
[Música]
Y en este festival de cine de cannes
conocimos al director chileno Felipe
Gálvez quien tuvo el honor de presentar
su primera película Los colonos en la
sección una cierta mirada
los colonos se desarrollan en 1901 en la
Patagonia chilena José Menéndez un rico
terrateniente interpretado por Alfredo
Castro contrata a un soldado británico
un Mercenario estadounidense y un joven
mestizo para sacar de sus tierras a las
poblaciones autóctonas y así abrir un
camino hacia el Atlántico la cinta
revela un capítulo oscuro y borrado de
los libros de historia en Chile la
masacre de la tribu segnam en Tierra de
Fuego a manos de la aristocracia Blanca
se trata del primer largometraje de
Felipe Gálvez que le tomó 10 años de
trabajo
hay que pensar que no existía el canal
de Panamá comienzo del siglo 20 y que la
estrecha Magallanes era la única ruta
para conectar el Océano Atlántico con el
Pacífico y eso transformaba punta Arenas
y a tierra al fuego en un lugar de Gran
comercio y en el granero del mundo por
eso empezaron a llegar muchas oveja y
esto trajo un conflicto grande con el
pueblo sernam y la consecuencia de eso
fue un genocidio brutal que una página
que
chile borró de su historia habla también
no solamente de esa masacre de los
pueblos originarios de tu país sino
también de la posesión de la tierra y de
la posesión de la tierra en manos de
pocas personas
bueno las tierras y toda la isla todavía
le pertenece a la familia Menéndez
prácticamente toda la isla sigue siendo
de ello eso fue otro de los problemas a
la hora de firmar la película ya que no
había mucho espacios que no sean de
ellos hasta el día de hoy no sé cuántas
películas más vamos a hacer en Chile de
este tema eso no hacía querer tratar de
abordar la mayor cantidad de punto de
vista la mayor cantidad de personajes y
bueno una película violenta los colonos
una película
sobre la colonización política pero que
no queríamos ser ni panfletarios ni
propagandísticos por lo tanto nos
interesaba mucho que el personaje
Alfredo Ojalá mucha gente se sienta
identificado con él no como que el
personaje de Alfredo representa a un
tipo de empresario latinoamericano
justamente que resonancia tiene tu
película El día de hoy o qué quisieras
que la gente retenga tomando en cuenta
la situación de tu país todavía en chile
hay problemas con los mapuches por
ejemplo son pueblos que todavía luchan
por tener un espacio Bueno a mí me lo
que me interesaba es que se genera una
conversación a veces cuando uno se pone
del lado de las víctimas en Chile
Tuvimos una dictadura muy fuerte y un
país muy polarizado y cuando uno toma
una postura sobre una izquierda una
derecha Generalmente creo que no se abre
muchas discusiones uno no cambiar muchas
opiniones creo que los colonos se ponen
un lugar bastante va más atrás para el
pasado en un lugar que algunos
desconocemos y que es más difícil
situarnos no tiene que ver solamente con
tus posturas políticas y en ese sentido
creo que se arma tiene la capacidad de
generar una conversación y un debate y
el espectador puede decidir de qué lado
se siente asumen que se generaron
procesos de colonización y de Matanza
una vez que los países independizaron y
en cambio chile decide borrar de la
historia sus procesos de colonización y
lleva una vergüenza porque hoy en día lo
sellan situado a Chile son muñecos son
marcas de helados son chocolates
calcetines se entiende pueden ser
fotografías de ellos y los transforma en
la imagen del país Entonces cuando uno
borra una página una historia y después
transforma a la imagen de un país a un
pueblo que que se le cometió un
genocidio y no se explica a mí me parece
una violencia profunda los colonos de
Felipe Gálvez ganó el premio fipress Y
que otorga la prensa internacional en el
festival de cannes
y otro latinoamericano en la selección
oficial este año fue Rodrigo Moreno
autor de los delincuentes una cinta que
mezcla comedia drama carcelario y amor
pero sobre todo guiños a la historia del
cine
[Música]
uno de ustedes y que seguramente más de
uno
cometió un delito Román y Morán son dos
empleados de un banco en Buenos Aires un
día a Morán se le ocurre robarle al
banco el dinero equivalente a su salario
hasta su jubilación y sin quererlo Román
se ve ligado al robo y a su compañero de
trabajo así comienza a los delincuentes
una trágicomedia de tres horas de
duración en la que cada personaje vive
una serie de aventuras inesperadas y que
nos empuja a imaginar una utopía y si no
tuviéramos que vivir trabajando en el
papel de Morán y Román los actores
Daniel Elías y estebandy
con dos cabezas a veces o como si el
destino estaría compartido entre ellos y
tienen cierta idea o ideal de libertad
de salir del trabajo y y parece que no
es tan simple no a veces parece que es
más más simple vivir trabajando que sin
trabajar no y a la vez lo que espera me
parece un personaje
nada lo encuentra la poesía en el amor y
no como en el destino un poco ideal de
vivir en la naturaleza de con los
animales tener hijos caballos una casita
de madera
[Música]
es una una aventura
realmente Una aventura creo
cinematográfica y estos dos personajes
los presenta la película en un con una
rutina de vida y con un trabajo en el en
el en un banco rutinario y y hay de
alguna manera Uno de los personajes el
de Morán que es el que tracciona un poco
la historia que es algo que decía Daniel
el otro día que es muy cierto como el
que va tomando decisiones riesgosas y mi
personaje Román va viviendo las
consecuencias de las decisiones de él es
una película que se empezó a filmar en
el 2018 y la Terminamos el año pasado y
hubo algo en eso de del viaje ese de ir
haciéndola en tanto tiempo que le
permitía también al director retirarse
editar la parte que se había filmado y
volver también con ideas nuevas
renovadas para las etapas siguientes fue
una construcción que estaba en de
entrada Porque también se fue haciendo
en el rodaje porque Estos espacios entre
entre rodaje y rodaje permitían también
seguir creando cosas y descubriendo a
los personajes Mi nombre es Laura Ortega
soy contadora pública nacional pero en
este caso estoy oficiando de
investigadora el autor de este juego
cinematográfico plagado de referencias a
la historia del cine es el argentino
Rodrigo Moreno a quien conocimos en
cannes
es que a partir de hoy cada uno de
ustedes está bajo sospecha nunca lo que
hago no está mirando el cine que mire
digamos no es algo que siempre estoy
atento es como si
pusiera en marcha la idea de como si el
cine si el lenguaje del cine tuviese un
verbo no es eso es pues estar atento al
uso del verbo cinematográfico
Entonces si la película está dialogando
con una forma de hacer cine en la
película está pensando en cómo el cine
Mira la realidad no y en relación a las
referencias hay de todo decir hay una
hay formas del cine gestos de son
propios del lenguaje del cine que a mí
me interesaban poner en escena en la
película la pantalla dividida los
fundidos Encadenados la palabra fin
cierto timbre musical en la música de
incidental de la película y después Sí
hay diálogo directo si hay momentos que
se ve el dinero de ebresón y los planos
que le corresponden son planos
brevesnianos Es un chiste con un juego
Hay algún espíritu del film noir hay un
espíritu también de como el cine francés
de los 60 revisita del cine clásico si
todo eso está dando vueltas ya para
terminar Rodrigo cómo te sientes
presentando esta película en cannes De
hecho no sé si lo sabes pero fue la
primera película en el momento de la
presentación que se nombró los
delincuentes bueno inmejorable no como
el mejor escenario donde podés presentar
una película es la sala de UCI por lo
menos no sé donde yo presenté la
película un cine increíble porque
prefiero que hoy el mundo está hablando
de las series no habla de las películas
ya este las series ocupan el lugar que
ocupó el cine en el siglo 20 no decir
donde en una reunión donde no hay gente
del mundo de las artes se hablaba de qué
película viste fuiste a ver al cine y
ahora es qué serie estás mirando no y
Bueno en ese contexto venir con esta
película que de alguna manera es un OVNI
es el mejor escenario donde donde puedo
presentarla y está buenísimo en la
primera vez que vengo te felicitamos por
haber estado acá y te agradecemos por
este tiempo que tomaste para nosotros
Muchas gracias Rodrigo Moreno
[Música]
aquí ponemos punto final este
cubrimiento del Festival Internacional
de Cine de cannes Esperamos que lo hayan
disfrutado tanto como nosotros y
cerramos Este programa con el filme de
animación que cerró el festival la cinta
de animación elemental tres dos uno
ellos son los residentes de Ciudad de
elementos
aire siempre tiene la cabeza en las
nubes
mi chaqueta nueva tierra puede ser algo
movediza
no estamos haciendo nada raro es solo
una podadita agua siempre se está
metiendo en algo
[Música]
ayuda y fuego su orden se nos calientan
los ánimos
[Música]